the john wick franchise takes place in a
stylish reality that while captivating
doesn't always make total sense here are
a few questionable aspects of the john
wick movies that many fans choose to
ignore
how are there so many assassins in one
place at any given time new york in
particular appears to be infested with
them as the story of john wick continues
it becomes apparent that wick isn't the
only assassin around the continental
hotel for example is an entire boarding
facility dedicated to provide a safe
space for those in the business to relax
have a drink and restock on whatever
weapons and ammo they might need when
jon is declared excommunicado by winston
the owner of the new york continental at
the end of john wick chapter 2 every
single person who happens to be outside
during the public meeting turns out to
be part of the criminal underworld as
wick begins his hour-long head start
many of the people he runs past read the
excommunicado notification on their cell
phones and look at him with solemn
recognition it's a striking scene that
shows how relatively powerless wick is
when compared to the authority of the
all-seeing high table but don't think
about it too hard or it might lose some
of its movie magic why do we ignore this
plethora of murderous hit people or
congregating in the same public place it
does make sense that they'd all be near
the continental and that the various new
york mobs would have enforcers stationed
nearby but 100 of the people there it
doesn't make sense even in the world of
wick with this many assassins around the
underworld sees this being the
underworld at this point it's just the
world
in the shadowy black markets of the john
wick franchise the gold coin is the
currency of choice wick's stash of gold
buys him everything from a taxi ride for
his dog to corp's disposal medical
attention guns a new suit all of it
costs a single coin each and no one ever
refuses it as payments as explained by
sci-fi wire the coins aren't just about
payment but about a code that keeps
everyone working for the mythical
world's high table on the honor system
instead of representing a set amount of
money a coin represents a favor that can
be redeemed for anything else one might
need that is unless you're shopping at a
normal store like a normal person
assassins need to eat too after all we
know from the first film that viggo
tarasoff has plenty of cash alongside
his coins and that other mob bosses have
enough cash lying around that it needs
to be laundered additionally bounties
posted on the operator's board are
offered not in coins but in cold hard
cash what makes something worth paying
coins and not cash if coins are the
currency that buys loyalty and silence
why offer cash at all everyone has
regular money in this world the trouble
starts for germany's buying gas after
all but the exact nature of this
underground economy doesn't exactly add
up
in the scene where viggo tells joseph
exactly who and how dangerous john wick
is he refers to him as baba yaga as well
as the boogeyman or more accurately he
was the one you sent to kill the [ __ ]
the only problem is that john wick is
nothing like baba yaga at least not the
virgin from russian folklore according
to the legend baba yaga is an old witch
who eats children and lives in a house
that walks on chicken legs yes she and
wick are both russian but that's about
where the similarities end baba yaga is
a russian boogeyman used to scare
children into behaving but wick is
nothing like her if the fairy tales are
to be believed it's a cool nickname
though and sounds very intimidating
which is probably why wic fans are
willing to look past it one thing the
john wick franchise has plenty of is
mayhem while some of it occurs in dark
rooms and elaborate set pieces most of
it occurs in public spaces where most of
the people present are presumably
innocent bystanders drawing some of
those public fights bystanders scream
and scatter as soon as bullets start
flying in other cases though no one
seems to notice the violence taking
place right in front of them probably
the least plausible of these fights is
the final altercation between john wick
and cassian the bodyguard of giana the
woman john has been sent to assassinate
in john wick chapter 2. john and cassian
take shots at each other in a subway
station while everyone else continues to
go about their business seemingly
unaware that a firefight is going on
sure both men have silencers on their
guns but silencers don't really work
that way john and cassian's fight being
ignored is a little easier to forgive
once they actually get on the subway
after all you know what they say about
new york subway riders there's also the
grand central station fight in john wick
chapter 3 parabellum where zero and his
henchmen go after jon as crowds of
passersby go about their business and as
bodies drop left and right no one bats
an eye yes new yorkers generally like to
keep to themselves but frankly this is
ridiculous john wick is a fearsome
killing machine known for his ability to
take out entire squads of combatants on
his own according to rotten tomatoes his
body count throughout chapters 1-3 adds
up to a whopping 299 and that's just
what we see on screen
so why does everyone seem to like him so
much it's not just the code that seems
to keep people from messing with wick
once he's retired and settled down
everywhere he goes in the first film he
commands respect sharon the concierge of
the continental and winston both seem
very fond of him harry another assassin
helps him out which costs him his life
aurelio clearly has deep respect for him
in the sequels the bowery king also
seems to give wick a lot of leeway
despite their past interactions being
less than constructive is it the dogs
that was played as a dark joke at times
wick's return to the life is fueled by
the theft of his car and the death of
his dog which stings particularly bad
since the dog was a posthumous gift from
his late wife helen but this is john
wick baba yaga a man who once killed
three people with a pencil by all
accounts he's killed more people than
freddy krueger and jason voorhees
complained he's pretty damn scary if
he's coming after you and you probably
wouldn't be inclined to greet him with a
smile but he likes dogs so that makes
him a heck of a guy
another questionable thing wic fans
ignore is how often wick's opponents
will give him a moment to compose
himself before they continue fighting to
the death the best example of this is a
final boss fight for the zero and his
henchmen in parabellum john manages to
escape to the continental after being
chased by zero and his men and he
appears to be safe however winston
defies the high table and the
continental is deconsecrated meaning
once forbidden activities are now
allowed on the grounds zero's martial
artists henchmen fight with john in the
continental they are fresh for fighting
while jon is tired from all the
relentless attacks he survives so far
they have a clear advantage over him
several times yet they continuously stop
the fight to give john a chance to
compose himself ostensibly as a sign of
honor they have a job to do but they're
apparently so thrilled to fight the
legendary john wick that they wind up
losing instead in most other films jon
would have been dead several times in
that fight and in many of the others he
gets into as well but in the john wick
world like in a child's game of tag
timeouts are a natural part of combat
there's nothing like a good fight scene
on motorcycles but anyone who knows
anything about bikes can't help but
scoff at moments like when john flips
one cycle to take out another it's a
cool looking stunt but it also defies
the laws of physics when you look at the
behind the scenes of stunts such as the
motorcycle chasers in the third film the
use of cgi is made quite apparent
similarly wic can fall off the roof of a
skyscraper and survive thanks to the
magic of computers as well as the
stunned men who get paid to do the
dangerous work keanu reeves doesn't do
himself series director chad stahelski
is a former stuntman himself so he knows
full well what is physically possible
and what isn't in a world as large and
outrageous as that of john wick sahelsky
knows that only the biggest and most
outlandish stunts will suffice so maybe
a motorcycle wouldn't fly backwards but
would instead slide off to the side but
it sure does look cooler when it happens
in the movies
sure dunwick takes place in a highly
stylized fictional world where anything
goes but as its scale grows across
borders and oceans it becomes
increasingly difficult to believe that
the machinations of the high table have
gone completely unnoticed and then
checked by outsiders the films make it
clear that at least one police officer
knows who john wick is a trope not
uncommon for mob movies but there is no
sense of exactly what an average
bystander believes eunan john
evening jimmy
noise complain
noise complaint
john wick features gruesome kills in
public spaces huge explosions and even
that one moment where wick rides a horse
through the city so if everyone's trying
to stay totally unseen they're not doing
a very good job the franchise posits
that there is a code among the assassins
dictating that no bystanders are to be
harmed but there must be collateral
damage at some point which would then
come with cops investigations and once
the truth is discovered worldwide
headlines jimmy the police officer who
knows jon is presumably on the payroll
so is everyone else in the world as well
is anyone glimpsed on screen truly
innocent it's hard to tell gastly
yeah gas leak
joseph tarasava is portrayed by alfie
allen as an indolent spoiled brat he's
entitled arrogant and unfortunately for
him not very bright but seriously how
does he not know who john wick is once
our elio realizes the car joseph has
brought to his chop shop belongs to wick
he rats him out to his father viggo the
head of the tarasov crime family vigo
has a talk with his insubordinate son
explaining that john wick is more than
just some assassin he's the most feared
enforcer of all and he was once on
vigo's payroll josef in all of his
entitlement thinks he can just take out
jon himself but he has no idea of the
wrath about to come his way the thing is
everyone in the wick world knows who
john wick is they know the gruesome
stories they know his nicknames they
know he got out of the business for love
how does joseph the son of wick's former
boss not to recognize the man he took
everything from even after jon spoke the
same russian dialect to him yosef's
clearly a major part of his father's
business even if he's not the best
employee in the organization yes joseph
is a dope but it seems odd that he had
never even heard of the man who killed
all of his father's enemies in a single
bloody night
the john wick franchise has filled with
impossibilities but one of the more
questionable ones involves jon's long
trek through the desert in john wick
chapter three parabellum after being
declared excommunicado and finding
bharada the master of coin sophia's
former boss who is in charge of the coin
making jon learns that he cannot find
the high table but rather that they must
come to him he is told to walk and walk
until he can walk no more and if he's
deemed worthy the high table will scoop
him up and allow him to speak to the
elder so john walks alone for days
without water and collapses he should be
dead there is nothing around him for
miles yet the high table finds him
easily and picks him up how does a high
table locate wick do they have invisible
drones exceptionally powerful binoculars
did they somehow hide a tracker on him
for that matter how does a high table
function at all there are obviously
switchboard operators the elder and the
adjudicator but how do they keep
everyone in line all of these are
questions that may never be answered
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]